so american underdog the kurt warner
story you play kurt warner i do yeah and
this premiered last night and then it
was last night where mad chinese
and how much fun was it
it was super fun i mean
you know i mean
you you you you go and make a thing you
believe in it you hope that it all comes
together i've seen it i i feel like it's
all there you know i'm proud of it we
made it in the middle of the pandemic
and all the craziness and
um
and then you go and do all the work and
doing the press and and then it and then
it's here and then you're like okay well
i hope and it's not even really open
right so it's like you know we premiered
last night but it doesn't open till
christmas so right i still won't really
know what critics or people or whatever
think about it but right this will have
aired this will have aired by the time
yeah the movie will be out so if you're
listening to this folks uh the movie's
out you the movie's out
and hopefully you've seen it and if you
haven't please go see it and if you do
see it i hope you enjoy it and if you
don't enjoy it then
f u no then uh no you know f use no i
mean people are allowed to not enjoy
things yeah i enjoy it i was gonna go a
different way with that joke i wasn't
just gonna like lambast people for not
liking my face and if you don't like
idiots if you don't like it what
and then kick rocks then watch shazam no
i don't know then yeah then watch sam
there you go watch shazam i'm proud of
it i i really do think we made it uh a
good little movie and it's got so much
heart heart and and and hope i mean it
and faith and you know there's it's it's
a very inspiring story it's true story
kurt warner you know he was uh he was
this you know good old boy from iowa
always wanted to be the next joe montana
and then uh didn't get a lot of play in
college in
northern iowa uh university but he got
just enough where he got this last
minute you know a tryout with the
packers right out of college and
and he me he miffed it he just he
couldn't step up to that occasion it was
it was way too much for him in that
moment wow he was a great player but i
mean there's a lot you know he's
watching far throw throw passes in front
of him you know as they're going through
like training camp he's like what is
this this is insane
so then that doesn't happen and then he
kind of just he goes and wanders in the
wilderness for a while he had met brenda
his now wife he wanders in the
wilderness he just takes away he goes
away from football well yes and no so
like in the in the midst of all this he
meets his now wife brenda and she's such
an integral part of their entire story
and you know uh
he
he in large part became the man that he
is the leader he is and the quarterback
that he was because of her love and her
faith in him and wow his love and her
faith in in her and
her children she uh had two kids at the
time her oldest son zach and their and
her baby daughter jesse and he took them
on and he took them on as a 21 year old
you know college kid essentially because
he just he felt
he felt his health yeah he felt this
love for them and he and this compulsion
and yeah absolutely and i think you know
very much god i mean their their journey
is so incredibly blessed and the ways
it's all kind of worked out but
ultimately you know she was this 24 year
old divorcee with two kids and her
oldest son or her her oldest who
her son zach he was dropped uh as a baby
on his head by her former husband and he
ended up having uh intellectual
disabilities and so she was quite a
package you know as a young mother and
and uh and i think you know partly
because kurt grew up also in a with a
single mom for you know a lot of his
life and him his brother and so i think
that there was this you know that that
story was already kind of being laid the
groundwork was already being laid a
little bit in his heart and his mind and
and he could recognize that and see that
and it's amazing that he could be that
strong at 21. oh yeah because i'm 49 and
i i i can't take on uh yeah i think i
could barely take on a dump in the
morning yeah yeah we know um
but uh no yeah it blows my mind that he
you know he valued he saw value in that
he wanted to keep seeing how that road
went and then they kept falling deeper
in love his uh relationship with zach
right out of the gates i mean the first
day he goes to like basically surprise
brenda at he had just met her at a honky
tonk like at a bar doing line dancing
he's like i want to i want to hang out
with you and she's like you don't want
to hang out with me on 24 i got two kids
you know blah blah and then he finds out
where she lives and she and he goes and
just brought her flowers and she was
like in the middle of something and her
son zach opened the door by the way
intellectually disabled also blind and
he opens the door and he loved radios it
would listen to music all the time and
he opens the door and kurt's there and
he grabs kurt's hand i mean
the the details in the movie versus what
actually happens in real life are very
very similar i'm not sure that we got
them you know to the point but
essentially
this little boy leads him into the house
and uh because he needs help with this
radio he needs his radio needs batteries
and he can't get anybody to help him
because his mom's getting ready to go to
school or work or whatever
and uh and he goes and gets kurt to go
find him batteries and puts batteries in
and then he like wants him to lay down
on the on the cool of the bath of the
bathroom floor just listen to music with
him
and like that really happened and it's
really in the script and i remember
getting to that point in the script and
i was like i've never
seen something so pure like that seems
like such a pure moment to have on a
screen and like the love that that
starts building and the love that he
starts building with brenda and anyway
their whole journey is amazing and then
ultimately
he yeah he wasn't playing football he
couldn't play football there was no
football to be played he was trying to
figure out how to get another shot in
the nfl um
they were super struggling you know
scraping change out of car doors to put
gas in their tank like that those types
of you know things that a lot of us can
relate to
going through some harsh iowa winters
and all that stuff and so he started
stocking shelves at a grocery store yeah
the hyvee and he did that for i don't
know six months to a year or something
and in the process of that this arena
football had started to kind of pop up
but he was he kept it out on arm's
length because he felt like
and i totally understand too i could
totally understand his mentality of
feeling like well that's
if i go do that then i'm giving up on
the real thing this is the this is the
jv so this is whatever that is but but
i'm you know what i mean like this is
where guys end up if they can't play nfl
or they're done with the nfl right and i
don't want to believe that
and i you know i think there was just so
much interesting up and down and in both
he and brenda's journey and their
journey together um that there was a lot
of just you know i don't know humbling
almost in some respects right because he
gets to this point where he's like i
don't want to stock shelves anymore and
i can make better money and i get to do
a thing that i i really love doing that
gives me purpose which is to go have a
ball in my hand like football basketball
yeah he did it all but football
specifically
and uh and so you know he he gives in to
the uh
to this guy who had the arena team um
the iowa barnstormers in in iowa
in the local arena team and he'd been
bugging kurt like come on you got to
come play for me he saw him play in
college or whatever knew he got a shot
with the packers but didn't go anywhere
and kurt kept like no no no no no no and
then fine he's like okay fine let's go
play i mean this is such a compelling
amazing story yeah it's insane it's it's
it's one of those things where
well hold on it gets better well you
know the story right you know the end of
it and all that no that's why i'm ready
for the movie so you know don't give it
away i don't really know the end of it i
know he makes the rams yes but you know
what happened with the rams well he ends
up winning the super bowl yes and he won
and all that
anyway so point is he goes and plays
arena and
in doing so he actually gets some looks
now again from the nfl
uh and
ultimately does get this opportunity
with the rams and uh he he was a you
know his his first year in this in the
league he was like 27 very old rookie
you don't have rookies coming into the
nfl 27 27 i think yeah 27. and then the
next and he didn't play at all 20 and he
was like a third backup quarterback
second season
second backup quarterback or something
like that i think he had made it up to
the number two spot
trent green is their number one who was
a
very talented quarterback at the time
and everybody had a lot of high hopes
high hopes for him
and um um vermeel was her head coach he
it was like his kind of cinderella story
too because after
philadelphia he kind of went off and
into the his own wilderness and came
back and so he's head coaching mike
martz is a offensive coordinator who has
this incredible offense he's worked out
with all of these incredible tools in
this team and the rams like really have
a shot and then trent green and
preseason down injury uh in season
injury uh season ending injury wow and
that's how he got a shot well yeah but
here's the thing i mean the rams also
like i'm sure they were calling around
they were like is there anybody because
you know this guy was still this
untested 28 year old now rookie we've
got kurt warner in the in our pocket
yeah let's get someone else because
let's try it yeah and look at the end of
the day it was kurt's because no one
else was available nobody else worked it
was all and they're like so dig for meal
and there's this yeah very famous
uh uh press conference because there was
a lot of heat also like the media was
like what are you there was all these
you know um stories and things going on
like espn like who's this are they gonna
you know put the whole the weight of the
team and and the season on this guy's
shoulders this guy who just came out of
the arena league and all that so there's
all that narrative going around and then
dick for me he has this press conference
and he goes we are going to rally around
kurt warner and we're going to play good
football i mean it's this really great
clip it is it almost seems fictitious it
does it does if you tell us if you know
when when this all happened in real life
when
then kurt steps in and then basically
leads the team as a 28 year old rookie
with very few snaps that he ever you
know
he takes the team all the way to the
super bowl wins the super bowl he wins
mvp of both the season and the super
bowl and was making league minimum when
he did it like there were guys league
minimum what's league minimum i don't
know what it was back then it wasn't a
lot of money no but i but i know that
there are people in the organizations
the football organizations that like
tend to the and by the way it's a very
big job tending to like the fields right
like the greens men for like to they
take care of sure some of those people i
believe i heard it quoted some of those
people make more than what he was making
as league minimum so the guys that were
you know tending to the fields were like
cool this guy who was this guy and
what's he doing so things changed
obviously after he won the super bowl
yeah well they they had a payday
hopefully yeah yeah i don't know i don't
know that you know you don't know that
part of it who knows who knows you know
but um
but at the end of the day it was just
this incredible thing we all happened
you know we were watching it happening
in real time i was i was 19 living in
ventura watching this
crazy [ __ ] go down like this is history
happening in our lifetime like what the
heck and then also because you know
being a person of faith and
he he being a person of faith there was
that spiritual kind of connection too
and even more inspiring in that regard
and uh so yeah and that was are you guys
close
i would say we're pretty close at this
point yeah was it was it weird in the
beginning because it's like i'm playing
you were you kind of like you know i
want to do you right man i'm you know
this is i'm only as good as this script
here i'm going to give you some
personality what fears did you have
going into that i mean the fears that
look when we take on a fictitious
character there's nobody
that can really hold us well a real
no kurt is very fictitious he's very
he's a fake person he is a phony man